I believe I can fly I believe I can
touch the sky I think about it every
night and day spread my wings and fly
away what are you doing I'm in the zone
I hear I thought you were testing your
levels
I was testing your patience
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
middlemost podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn
wait oh my god oh my god and then Josh
this whole time and I'm Ryan Nicodemus
all right man come on all right let's
start it up here we go all right hello
everybody welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua fields Millburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists and we are broadcasting
from our new podcast studio who you are
this is episode 118 it's about
collecting and eighty-four percent of
you asked for it wait what
I knew they were asking for it what were
they what were they asking for well
actually you and I were just talking
about this before we hit the record
button here we're back in the saddle
again oh yeah all right so so before we
so we took a little pause from social
media throughout January and actually
this episode be out first week of
February and so we're back on social
media hopefully we'll we'll spend maybe
next next week's episode talking a
little bit about what we've learned from
that whole experience but being off of
social media we before we before we
jumped off we put this a little survey
out there and said hey how many of you
what do you prefer would you prefer our
in-studio podcast episodes or you do you
prefer the live episodes and all the
feedback we got was overwhelming but a
lot of people basically said hey love
your live episodes but really prefer the
in studio episodes and so we've moved
out here to Los Angeles California this
is our first episode in our new studio
space I can't wait to share it with you
all we just had the sound panels put in
here this week that's why it sounds so
crisp so clean and eventually we're
gonna add a video version of the podcast
as well we'll put that up on on YouTube
once we get to enough patreon supporters
but you can go and subscribe to our
YouTube channel now and get any new
videos we put out there it's just
youtube.com slash the minimalists but
yeah we are we're back in studio man
yeah I am so thankful for our patreon
supporters man because if it wasn't for
them we would not have this in fact one
of them emailed me the other day they're
like can we have an interview can we
have a tour of your new studio yeah and
just for the patreon supporter or
definitely that we don't have the
lighting setup and you're actually
tomorrow we're supposed to set up some
lighting so if I were to take pictures
right now
even though the space looks great it
wouldn't look good on camera because
we've already done some stuff we have
some lighting being installed tomorrow
the sound panels are in we got this
beautiful paint it's just like dark gray
paint and black sound panels we've got
our new studio table here in front of us
we're investing in some new equipment as
well and as soon as we reach that next
threshold on patreon we will have enough
money to to do the video version that's
really want to focus a lot on this year
is doing a lot more video work I'm
putting up on on YouTube and you know
it's the same podcast Sean I wouldn't
have it any other way
ladies and gentlemen podcast Sean here
he's here in the room he's he's hiding
his face still so you can't see him and
we don't give him a microphone because
he sounds much more intelligence right
we don't want to sound any dumber than
we actually are so Ryan we're talking
about collecting collecting oh man I
love collecting only texting memories
I've been collecting viruses the last
two months ever since you Ryan in the
radio business um weird collections
before we call that a segue yeah off a
cliff
no I i man remember it so a couple
episodes ago we published our
our event are in Nashville with Griffin
house which was was great he played a
song he's one of our favorite musicians
and the next day is when I just got
deathly ill I had hen foot-and-mouth
disease which is a virus that usually
affects children but I was going I've
been going through that mercury detox
which I got rid of mercury but in the
process I think it really like beat the
hell out of my immune system and so I've
been prone to getting sick the last
couple months and that I feel great
today today the last three or four days
the first time I felt great in the last
two months I've I've gotten sick after
sick after sick and in fact I'm getting
my new apartment tested for mold this
week just to make sure that like I'm not
continually getting sick because there's
mold there and so tomorrow I got some
folks coming out to to take a look at
the mold situation but I feel great for
the first time in a while and so I'm
glad I'm not here you're under duress of
the many viruses that I've been
collecting yeah you're looking much
better I feel a lot better sleeping and
I'm excited to be back here and the
question I have for you to kick things
off before we hop into the listener
questions Ryan is have you ever had a
weird collection of anything in days of
yesteryear as a youth or in your 20s the
collection now really yeah I've got um I
have well so when we were on tour last
year the less is now tour I guess
technically we're still on that tour cuz
we're gonna Australia with it right
right but the North American losses now
tour so we found ourselves at all these
venues and some really amazing venues
like the Wilbur which is just like an
iconic beautiful theater in Boston yeah
it's almost like God heard Joe Rogan
explain he's shooting his next special
there yeah at the at the Wilbur theater
later this year and I heard him talk
about how it's kind of like having three
separate venues all together because
there's the three levels right yeah and
it makes it much more intimate even
though there's whatever 1,100 1,200
people there it feels like you're
talking to your three groups of
three or four hundred people and it
makes it much more intimate than than a
big space like that it's a great venue
yeah so so you know we went to all these
like really cool venues on the Fillmore
in San Francisco that's like an iconic
theater Bogaerts in Cincinnati very
iconic no no it's like its iconic for me
like that's that's that was like my very
first concert I ever went to never in a
million years that I think I would be
you know sitting backstage being you
know the the artist that was there yeah
and it smelled like weed
it's not even in body odor yeah really
did and Bogaerts which everyone was
really nice though because I've seen
concerts there before and but going back
there like the this roof was leaking so
they had trash cans in the middle of the
audience right - it was a it's a like a
heavy rock venue
yeah and we're getting up there trying
to talk about getting rid of your craze
or what right no it was it was great man
like I loved every minute of it I mean
even sitting back through with Lake you
know with the strange smells going on I
was still like oh my god I can't believe
I'm back here and and the green room of
Bogart's yeah but no so every venue we
went to we would get these backstage
passes essentially right and they all
pretty much have a similar type of look
to them they've got the name of the
venue and then they have a spot where
like they either put your name or you
know whatever they put there to to give
you permission to go back and forth from
backstage so when I was getting these
I'm like god I really want to like
really want to hang onto these I'm like
but this is it's stupid like what am I
gonna do with them put them in a
scrapbook I'm like I'm never gonna you
know like it's the thought of getting a
scrapbook out and sitting down with my
kids and being like oh here's the
sticker from the film or let me tell you
about the flake or worry I don't even
have kids so getting other people
writing other people other people's kids
look at it well two things
um I don't need a scrapbook to remember
the film or and be attempt from me I'm
not saying for everyone else out there
in the world but for me yeah having a
scrapbook which just it makes it's silly
for me right so what I did
as I had this idea because I already do
this on the bottom of my longboard is I
put different like band stickers and
stuff like coffee places I go to and you
get stickers and like I was sticking on
the bottom there so that's what I did
with all these all of these backstage
passes I didn't do it with every single
one of them but the ones that like
really stood out like marijuana really
stickers there are stickers yeah so
that's what the backstage pass was it
was a sticker okay you you got these I
just threw him out as soon as they had
probably yeah yeah so well you mean you
had to hold on to it - no I didn't there
was one venue they wouldn't let me it
was very confusing yeah there was one
video they did the same thing to me um
but anyway long story short yeah so
there were stickers and yeah I was just
like you know what I could totally like
make use of these and they do look
really freaking cool on the bottom of my
longboard so there you go so yeah so
that that is a it's a collection I have
and it's not intrusive it doesn't weigh
on my shoulders I don't ever you know
think to myself man I got it I got to
arrange this sticker collection somehow
I mean it's it's there is it's very
[Music]
unintuitive I don't know how well it's
it's a trigger for memories as well I'd
say the memory is obviously aren't in
the stickers themselves or so that you
didn't you know turn them into a cup and
keep your memories in there right like
the memories are in you and these will
allow you to trigger that in a way that
doesn't actually get in the way of your
overall experience like if you all of a
sudden decided well I'm not even gonna
talk to Mariah about this I'm just going
to put all these stickers all over our
floor right and she's really what are
you doing why are you doing that right
and anything I was crazy it would
negatively affect your household out
that way as well I think back to my 20s
and so you and I both grew up poor and I
remember when I first had access to any
sort of money the first thing I started
collecting was DVDs and it was at a time
where that's the way that you I mean you
would rent a DVD right you go to the
local Blockbuster yeah or we'd go what
was the place up on Deerfield Road crazy
Mike's made that no no no that's an
that's an was
he got in Heath owned it video gallery
gallery yeah yeah we used to do MBA jams
competitions you know karate or
something it's a totally new karate
like almost knocked out Jerome yeah my
brother yeah yeah
Heath is so old I think he was 22 ladies
I looked up to him like wow he's an
adult
he knows karate karate I mean you can't
get any cooler as an adult than owning a
video store where you rent video games
and knowing karate oh my god he's still
the coolest dude in my book so my
brother was like the toughest kid in our
school but he would go up there and just
mesmerized that this guy knew karate I
need to ask him to do like jump up and
do kicks and stuff anyway I have no idea
where oh yeah I sort of buying DVDs
instead of renting them and like then of
course had to get the sort of whatever
the bookshelf equivalent of a DVD holder
that mounts on the wall and then I'm
alphabetizing them and I realize like I
remember when I got the first big
Commission check and I was 18 and I'm
like oh man like I can I I can go buy a
DVD but I don't just have to buy one I
have I mean what is it it's a hundred
and fifty dollars to buy ten DVDs I
could buy ten DV I've got $150 Wow I can
buy ten DVDs yeah and and then of course
like I need more and more and then that
bled over to other things like I might
early 20s especially I remember being a
big fan of Al Pacino and like especially
his obscure movies like panic in needle
park and I want to say Sicario but
that's the that's a new film you don't
have to impress me with your obscure Al
Pacino movie so what he says no you're
out of order justice for all something
like that no idea yeah yeah so Shawn's
giving me the thumbs up there yes so so
anyway like I'd buy movie posters of
these things and photos or script signed
scripts from these like I'd go to ebay
and like buy a sign script from one of
these these you know
films and it be I didn't realize he did
that $70 or something yeah which I could
technically afford I couldn't really
because I was starting to put stuff on
credit cards or whatever ableo just pay
it off next month whatever and then I
was just buying it because I could not
because I should or I must or it's going
to truly add value to my life but I'm
just gonna collect this because I can
collect it because I had been deprived
for so long I felt like the answer to
that deprivation was collection and so I
didn't I don't think there's anything
inherently wrong with owning those
things necessarily but what was wrong is
why I was accumulating them just because
I could and I think now that you know
I've got a four year old she does a lot
of things just because she can do them
right she can throw something across the
room she can binge watch Daniel tiger or
Dinosaur Train and and because she can
it doesn't mean that she should do it
and right as adults we just do the the
same thing man that's like and that's
permeated like every every other culture
that that is trying to mimic what you
know the Western some what Western
civilization is doing I'm trying being
still - right now because I'm trying not
to like call out any other countries or
later you can even talk bad about the
culture what but there is this attitude
of if you can then you should yeah yeah
if you can then you must yeah and it's
like I mean how many times is that an
answer why did you do that because I can
mm-hmm why did you go into the oh
because I get it but that tends to be
the best answer that we come up with
quite often because it's the only honest
answer yeah but it seems like you know
looking at it from that perspective you
know looking at Ella it seems like a
like an irresponsible answer yeah yeah
absolutely is irresponsible so here's
one culture we can call out because they
called themselves out to me recently I
did a few interviews in Australia last
month actually back in December and just
over the phone with some different
newspapers different organs and they
were talking about the American Dream
permeating their borders and sort of
this idea of
if I can purchase it then I should
purchase it bigger is better and I don't
believe the bigger is worse or better I
think it's all circumstantial right here
is just bigger and and you know well
that's a bigger house or a bigger car or
whatever like what what what did the
circumstances dictate right and for me
the circumstances didn't mean I needed
to get the new or the the old actually
Al Pacino movie script that's signed I
didn't I didn't need those things I just
in fact I didn't even know why I wanted
them and if I would have sat down and
started asking myself some serious
questions like why do you want this what
void are you trying to fill with this
are you gonna get any value from are you
actually gonna sit down and read this
are you going to appreciate it as a
piece of art or are you just celebrating
the consumption and quite often I think
that's what I was doing I was I was
celebrating the act of consuming mm-hmm
and and I still see that that trigger in
me now and I think some of the questions
we have to answer today we can we can we
can jump into those because I really see
a reflection of myself and my own habits
that I've either changed or my own
proclivities that are very difficult to
change and they always creep back in to
into the picture our first question is
from Rome us there's this tug of war
between wanting to have fewer but more
meaningful objects in life and then
meaningful objects themselves just being
a fascinating thing to celebrate for
their beauty or craftsmanship or
usefulness or whatever and there's just
something about multiples a repeated
pattern and it can create a kind of
bigger effect one plus one plus one eye
is more than the sum of its parts
and I mean along the ways I've grown up
I've sold my coin collection I've given
away my baseball cards comic book
collections so I'm not necessarily
attached to these things but I still
find myself seeking out multiples you
know multiples of whatever vintage pens
fountain pens or life soldiers or
whatever
and that seems to be more like a
purposeful patterned activity with maybe
a larger meaning than just a kind of
blind hoarding of random stuff so my
question to you is can you reconcile the
collectors mindset with that minimalism
so right now the first thing I think
about is I don't really cool I mean
collecting is is in the eye of the
beholder right sure I tend not to
collect things for the sake of
collecting them
he used some interesting words here
about multiples and about the collection
being more than the sum of its parts and
the thing that I can think of in my own
life that is the only thing I can think
of that would be considered a collection
might be my bookshelf and I don't have a
whole lot of books maybe I don't know 50
40 I'm not sure I don't have a whole lot
of books but the books that I have I do
find them the experience of them
meaningful I don't find the objects or
the artifacts themself meaningful and
and so the first thing I would warn
anyone about is nothing is inherently
meaningful everything has only the
meaning that we give it if human beings
all of a sudden were wiped off the face
of the earth they all just spontaneously
combusted all 7 billion of us there
wouldn't be meaning in those objects
anymore right other than the meaning
that we did give to it right and so when
I think about when I think about meaning
within things it just means what is the
purpose it has for me and write those
books say they serve a few few purpose
for me one is I got a beautiful
bookshelf and it looks really good to
have them displayed it sort of looks
like art the way that they are displayed
on on this bookshelf but in addition to
that I find that they're useful because
there's some of my favorite books to go
back and reference and either share with
other people you know my partner backs
her and I were just going through the
books this past week and one of my
favorite authors is a woman named Mary
Karr and she's written three memoirs
that I mean I I was showing backside you
can open up to any pay
and it's just gorgeous writing it's like
poetic and and it's about these sort of
downtrodden scenes a lot of this stuff
takes place in West Texas and and sort
of trailer-park downtrodden but she
finds the true beauty just in the
sentence structure there and me being I
will pull that book out and show backs
that right there that that experience
and that sharing is meaningful the
artifacts sitting there on the shelf if
it's just sitting there it's not
meaningful it's just there yeah not
using it yeah I think the question that
you raised where you know is this
meaningful for me that's that's the
question I mean you know what what he's
asking here is you know can one
reconcile the minimalist mindset with
collecting the short answer is yes like
you absolutely can but the way you get
there it's not because Josh and I have
come up with some minimalist rule or we
have looked to the the ancient
minimalist philosophers and we're using
their their rules what Josh and I are
really trying to do is is help people
decide for themselves so the question
that he should be asking here isn't what
can one reconcile the question he should
be asking is is the collections that I
have that I desire to have are they
adding more value to my life or are they
adding more stress
now him asking this to me doesn't sound
like he's stressing out it sounds like
he has a collection that he really
enjoys right and he's looking for
permission to have it or he has a
conflict that sounds like yeah there is
some kind of conflict so the my answer
is is if you enjoy that collection if it
truly is adding value like the stickers
on my longboard um if that longboard got
shredded somehow on accident or you know
I lost it or sometimes stole it right
wouldn't miss a min sure I mean that's
and we've said that a lot like how are
you know one of the powers we have
gained over the last several years of
doing this is the power to let go yes
and have no attachment to any to
anything but to any you know physical
item but uh but what I'm saying is is
that for me that collection
it's unintrusive it does not take up any
extra space it takes up you know one
a little bit of extra small layer on the
bottom of my of my longboard what i'm
doing here is i'm showing my rules like
my rules are i'm not gonna have just you
know a collection of of something taking
up room in my house i'm certainly not
going to be cluttered there are there
are ways that mariah and i live our
lives and those stickers that i have on
the bottom of my longboard it does not
affect the way that mariah and i really
want to live our lives so that's the
question asked it's not is it okay for a
minimalist to collect things it's the
things that i want to collect as a
minimalist is it going to interfere with
the way that i want to live my life and
he used some interesting words in there
to follow up on that one word that I
wouldn't use he was talking about
celebrating these objects I don't want
to celebrate the material possessions in
my life and I think instead of celebrate
the world I would probably use is
appreciate and if you can ship it's a
slight shift in mindset but it changes
everything especially with those two
words that you just mentioned Ryan
letting go because it allows you if you
can appreciate the thing without
celebrating it it increases your ability
to be able to let go a few other words
that I would use there is instead of
celebrating the the the possessions
instead of the possessions being well or
maybe something were useful in fact
that's a word that he used he said I
want to celebrate their beauty or their
craftsmanship or their usefulness and I
think that's great I want to appreciate
the beauty I want to appreciate the
craftsmanship I want to appreciate how
useful those objects can be not a little
more going to be useful though right we
talked about adding value something adds
value if it serves a purpose that means
it's useful or if it brings me joy that
can be a piece of artwork on the wall it
could be my the the art of my book
collection right my bookshelf of books I
can I can appreciate the beauty of that
even if I'm not getting the same sort of
functionality out of it and the thing
that I'm thinking about here though is
those items that are being collected are
magnifying my
experience of life they're augmenting
the experience of life they they amplify
my experience of life and if I can say
that if I can say it
augmented amplifies its supplements and
magnifies it appends my experience of
life then that's great
too often though our collections end up
getting in the way
III think of if I go back to that DVD
collection a lot of that just sort of
made its way to my basement eventually
because I was having trouble letting go
of it because I was celebrating that
collection look at all these things I
have what does it say about me as a
person well I'm a complete person
without those things right and hopefully
they'll they will they will those things
will augment my experience of life
instead of just trying to be a part of
of my life the other thing that I think
about here is those those collections
those items that we collect quite often
we we like those things but sometimes we
just liked those things meaning I think
I'm supposed to hold on to this
collection because once upon a time I
liked it
mmm or maybe I told myself I liked it
and I didn't actually like it and and
when we get to that point where it's
like well I didn't actually I don't like
it now I liked it before and he
mentioned he had baseball card
collections and other things that he had
no problem getting rid of and I think
that's great and so maybe the thing to
keep asking here is do I still like this
is it still appropriate for my life and
if not then there's some sort of weird
imaginary value there right and and
because nothing is inherently meaningful
me even even money
I was meaningful only because it has
it's only valuable because we say it has
a value I agree that a dollar is worth a
dollar and you agree that same piece of
paper is worth a dollar once upon a time
it was gold and silver coins and before
that it was seashells that people all
agreed like this is the currency we use
to to to give to each other if I try to
pay you in seashells now you think I
would think I was a crazy person
Oh Joshy could pay me in seashells any
time
and and and that's just because the
things have the value that we say they
have and and we're agreeing that they
all have the same sort of value but
realizing that there isn't this
intrinsic value and the thing and so
that helps me let go because I realized
that like the thing either adds value to
my life or it goes back to the thing
with my with my Al Pacino scripts it was
something that was supposed to own for
whatever reason I just told myself like
well I'm supposed to own this I'm
supposed to collect this that's what
people do they have collections they
have their own little things that they
like and man tell you the truth I didn't
even like it I didn't spend much time
reading over those scripts I didn't like
really I didn't even appreciate those
things I celebrated them and that was
actually the problem yeah I'd love to
send Ramos a copy of our book it's an
essay collection called essential so
Shawn I think you reach out to him
there's a whole chapter in there about
stuff there's a chapter about minimalism
and in a second chapter about stuff
there's 12 chapters in total 12 areas of
living a more intentional life it's on
audiobook if you want to send that to
them if you like the podcast you'll like
the audiobook but it's also in book book
and ebook as well shown if you could
reach out to him and get him a copy of
essential I would appreciate that all
right next question is from Molly in San
Francisco I'm calling because I have a
question about what to do with things
like trophies and medals I'm on a dragon
boat team and in the last four years
we've run once the medals and in the
coming years I assume we'll win some
more medals they don't necessarily bring
me any value or joy so I would like to
get rid of them but I don't know if it's
something I should just toss in the
garbage or if somebody can actually use
the medal or if it's something I could
actually donate somewhere you guys have
any idea or do any of your listeners
have any idea of someone that could do
something with medals and trophies
man what to do with all those trophies
Molly congratulations on being an
awesome athlete it sounds like she's
winning her and her team we're winning a
lot of trophies yeah it's pretty awesome
I wrote something down here Ryan and I
don't know how true this is but it
seemed at least profound to me in the
moment I wrote down trophies look back
champions look forward yeah man and I
think about like whenever whenever we've
theoretically won something right like
if I feel really good about an
accomplishment or whatever you've
accomplished something like it's okay
just to appreciate that moment but wait
I don't want to just hug on to that
trophy just clinched it for the rest of
my life look at me look at me look I've
got this big trophy and so I want to say
congratulations to Molly because she's
already acknowledging that she's saying
look these don't really add value or
bring me they don't bring me joy really
and it sounds like they're even getting
in the way but she's like well should I
throw them out and my answer to you is
no and I saw I'm gonna link to in the
show notes we'll put a link to this
recycled Bank article and I decided a
little bit of research here for you
Molly because there's some stuff you can
do with old trophies so this is a
recycled Bank article it says old
trophies and medals are often made from
recyclable materials but they also hold
a value in their current form and many
can be reused so that's another way of
re recycling right is to have them just
be reused a number of companies have
programs dedicated to specific
specifically to the art of refurbishing
trophies the best-known of these is a
company called total awards and
promotions in Madison Wisconsin there's
also one called
lam awards and engraving in Maryland
these programs break unwanted awards
down for parts rebuild new trophies and
plaques with whichever parts are usable
and recycle and they recycle the rest
the rebuilt items are then donated to
nonprofit organizations or resold both
programs will allow you to ship trophies
that are in sufficiently good condition
for you know nominal shipping fee
basically and so it goes on to talk
about metals while metals are accepted
by these programs there are also options
dedicated specific
giving metals a new life there's a
program called sports metal recycling
it's Massachusetts based organization
and they they contribute all their
proceeds from recycling donated metals
to fundraising for different charities
so basically you do have some options
there's another company called metals
for metal they accept old marathon half
marathon and triathlete metals and they
give to kids who are fighting serious
illnesses so there's some resources for
you there to anyone else who is is
looking for a weight like there's weird
things that we don't think about
recycling and then it's like well [ __ ] I
guess I'll just throw this old trophy
out because I know one's going I can't
just give it to the goodwill it's like
look it's my eighth grade basketball
trophy and then there was another
article I'll put a link to I won't go
through all the stuff in here but this
one is from the Mother Nature Network in
in in how to dispose of eight odds
seemingly difficult to recycle items and
they talk about how to recycle
prosthetic limbs how to recycle your
bra's crayons old greeting cards this
one seemed odd your pets fur your
dentures fine I got something to do with
that collection of Macs hair then
building up
fill me up on your lint rollers oh my
goodness your sex toys you can donate
them which is actually I need to read
through this and old trophies already
talked about that so eight different
things you can go to there we'll put a
link to that in the show notes and and
here's the thing I mean we often don't
think about it like we collect these
things and we accept them without
thinking about how am I going to get rid
of this I know we're out on tour I
especially we could do bookstore tours I
love going to Xindi book shops but they
almost always want to give us a coffee
mug and a t-shirt every time we show up
and and I mean I can if we've done what
300 tour stops over the years and lost
count can you imagine going back home
with 300 coffee mugs and 300 your
bookstore t-shirts like I just I have to
say no upfront because it
makes for recycling a whole lot easier
on the back end if you say no now I
don't have to say no to the thing later
on it becomes more difficult
I see what you're saying and what you're
saying is is you don't have to worry
about the clutter if you don't
accumulate the clutter oh my god
that's genius we've been saying this
whole time you know I was when I was
looking for ways to recycle trophies I
was like mostly the same thing you did
cuz I found the same two articles the
other thing that I found while googling
was this Pinterest and I'll shoot this
over to Shawn so he can put it in the
show notes but it was this Pinterest
like oh look at all these amazing things
you could do with trophies but some of
them actually are kind of cool I mean
you know if you're into art and other
art projects and things like that yeah I
mean that's the other thing we've talked
about in the past we've we've talked to
our audience and we've had different
people who who take these old sort of
heirlooms especially like old clothes
that maybe people aren't going to use
and they like they'll take their mothers
old jean jacket and frame it and turn it
into some like piece of art that they
can put on their wall and they can then
appreciate it as opposed to it sitting
in a box and it calls it somewhere no
one's ever gonna use my favorite or
heirloom tomatoes collection I do you
know when my mom left me all these
heirlooms it was a box of tomatoes it's
great when I was listening to Molly's
question let me think about my most
prized trophy and it was a it was a
third-place trophy I got I got in a
four-wheeler in an ATV race and I was so
proud of myself because dude it is it
looks so easy when you see people like
riding their bikes on a track but like
when you actually do it it's you injured
yourself so many times I put bikes put
on a four-wheeler it's like your breast
your wrestling four hundred pounds for
like 15 laps dude it's unbelievable
you're riding a mechanical bear I
thought I was gonna die afterwards
anyway it looks like it was really
awesome but when you know when it
finally came time for me to like you
know face this object and get rid of it
yeah I don't even think I took a picture
of it because I kind of thought well you
thought I'm like Ryan do you want
sit here and tell the story about how
you won third place in this ATV race man
I like thinking about it that way I was
like yeah dude just get rid of the
trophy like what's the uncle's name and
Napoleon Dynamite it kind of feels like
that yeah yes it does he just reliving
Rico baby
no that sounds right Shawn's giving me
the the the not is a yeah and where he's
just sort of throwing the football
everywhere I imagine you like particular
four-wheeler yeah cuz it was like this
yeah I could jump a 40-foot tabletop
please tell me there are more than three
people in this competition alright so
let's go on to the lightning round Molly
I want to leave you with one thing here
there's an essay that we have on our
website called collecting is dangerous
I'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well it goes a little something
like this
collecting material possessions is not
unlike hoarding take it from two former
hoarders uh-hum collectors of stuff the
word collector just sounds way nicer no
matter how hard we try to hide behind
euphemisms and other semantic trickery
though the truth will always find us
don't believe us look it up the Oxford
American writers thesaurus lists the
following synonyms under the first
definition of collection here are the
synonyms with collection yo hoard pile
heap stockpile it's strange
there are myriad TV shows websites and
clubs all dedicated to collecting things
not creating things but collecting them
we don't believe there's anything
inherently wrong with owning material
possessions but we do wonder why so many
of us collect things why do we give our
belongings so much meaning the things we
collect become elements of us our
collections become part of our
identities but what happens when we take
away our collections are we not the same
beautiful people actually when we
jettison are superfluous possessions we
discover we're already perfect beautiful
through and through and that's one thing
I have to think about if I were to
quickly turn this into a therapy session
Ryan which we do a lot of the time it's
not a maths podcast we don't turn it
into that it's funny with this new
studio where and we actually have a
therapist of rec late for us the hall
and yeah I'm tempted sometimes like
because I still experience the same sort
of feelings like I want to collect
things I want to bring new things into
my home and and now that we moved out
here to California and I'm slowly sort
of populating our home with stuff like
this stuff that we need I also feel this
pool to lay oh I need this this
decorative item and actually next week
on next week's podcast where we're going
to do a separate podcast episode about
decorations and I think that one Ryan is
really gonna turn into a therapy episode
for me I'm gonna need your counsel and
because woody you don't have a lot of
decoration I know and that that's the
thing I have very few but I feel the
sort of pole of man May I should get
this thing or I saw that thing in the
magazine that would be a good combo I do
yeah I appreciate the aesthetic beauty
but but I also need to be careful and
realize like look I'm complete without
this and so a preview for next week the
one thing that I want to talk about next
week is I don't have the rule of like no
artwork on my walls ever my rule is
actually the opposite of that I'm
complete without any artwork on my walls
and therefore if I do end up wanting to
put something on my walls in the future
I can go into it recognizing like this
doesn't make me a more complete person
this isn't part of my identity this is
just something to perhaps make the space
more beautiful right and is it actually
going to bring me joy or is it what I'm
supposed to do and so I think that's
that's something to think about we will
talk a lot more about that next week but
in the meantime we'd love to hear what
you all have to say oh wait Molly Molly
Molly Molly you're in San Francisco
which isn't far away from Los Angeles
and so we have an event this weekend and
we're filming a new documentary it's
called the minimalists les is now to
follow up to our Netflix documentary
minimalism we're gonna die I have a lot
deeper into my life and Ryan's life back
stories but we're building it around
this talk so we went out and we gave
this two separate talks over the last
year and fifty different cities and now
we're finally ready to record it in this
beautiful space we found the space
called electric Pony Studios in Los
Angeles on February 10th we are
recording a 3 p.m. show and a 7 p.m.
show 3 p.m. show is already sold out but
there's still a few tickets left for the
7 p.m. show so male I'd love to give you
a couple tickets if you're interested in
being a part of that taping so we're
gonna film that talk and we're gonna
build this next documentary around that
talk so Shawn if you can reach out to
Molly and maybe give her a couple
tickets if anyone else is interested
they can find taken information over on
our website the minimalists comm just
click on the tour page over there you
can find all of our our dates there if
there are still tickets left all right
Ryan we'd love to hear what the audience
has to say so if you have a comment or
tip about collecting including advice
for any of our callers today this is my
favorite part of the show in fact we
need more of these because we get a ton
of questions people call in all the time
with questions we we can't possibly
answer every single question Ryan we'd
have to do 7 podcast episode today I
think to answer everyone's question but
we really appreciate heck we celebrate
your comments because they help us out
they help the people in our audience out
because it gives people different
perspective so it it radically I was
gonna say gradually but actually it
radically increases your chances of
being on the show if you have a comment
or tip for any of our listeners today or
any comment or tip about collecting then
leave us a voicemail for zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine or you
can just send a voice memo right from
your phone to the email address podcast
at the minimalists comm we will air our
favorite comments and tips on a future
episode and I'll learn a whole lot from
it Ryan what time is it you know what
time it is it is time for our lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media we are on Twitter Facebook
and Instagram at the minimalists during
the lightning round so Ryan and I we do
our best to answer each question with
just a short shareable less than 140
character response we also put the
to these minimal Maxim's in the show
notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like and you can now find all of our
pithy quotes in one place minimal
Maxim's com our friend Jessica Lynne
Williams she she curates all of our
quotes and puts them there and minimal
Maxim's dot-com
our first lightning round question is
from Kelly Kelly asks whoa she writes in
this a long one just give me a second
now that we've got 280 characters on
Twitter well actually I we we spoiler
here we actually didn't recording this
while we're off social media so I had to
go to our patreon supporters for these
for these questions that's why it's so
long yeah there's no it's a great trivia
question though
all right so so Kelly Wrightson I am NOT
a collector but live among avid
collectors my husband and two children I
often feel overwhelmed by the volume of
things they have I've recently sold and
donated many items I no longer and joy
and I hope I'm setting a good example
Kelly it sounds like you are but it
doesn't feel any less cluttered here how
can i lovingly express how I feel about
their collections
without making them feel like they can't
collect the things they bring that bring
them joy well my short answer is that
I'll have a little aside a little rant
here my short answer is clutter is in
the eye of the beholder
and I think I think that you might be
looking at their collection and saying
in its clutter they're looking at their
collection and saying it's a collection
and it's different right now it also
changes over time you might look at your
old collection like I look at my old
collections and say the thing that was
once a a collection the thing that I
liked I no longer like and there's a
huge difference between liked and liked
and what you're telling me right now is
there's something that that you don't
like and it's something they they do
like and so the metaphor for me is
really the the the the not nice way to
ask his question is how do I force the
people my family to get rid of their
stuff now she's asking it not in that
way and she's actually trying to be very
considerate and she's doing many
the right things like I'm trying to set
the example for them right but but if
what if I were to ask the question this
way Ryan like how do I convince you to
put your hand in the garbage disposal
hmm you'd be like what
let's have to give me a pretty good
argument and it's because you is why
wouldn't you want to put your hand to
garbage disposal right serious no why
why wouldn't you wanna put why wouldn't
want to put it in there because my hand
would be disposed of it would hurt it
would definitely hurt yes and you're
gonna feel pain in doing that and I
can't think of a good reason for you to
do that right now
there could be one you know to save your
child's life or whatever like there's
some some reason insert good reasons
yeah and and the point being is you're
not willing to make that that that
decision that's going to cause you an
immense amount of pain and right now all
they're seeing in the letting go of the
clutter or the collection is in the
grossest movie and they're seeing the
pain it's because you have different
expectations so what you say I see what
you're saying here dude what you're
saying is is Kelly should first pitch
her family to put their hands in the
garbage disposal right and then and then
suggest that they declutter a little bit
guys wouldn't this be easier than
putting your hand and the garbage
disposals exactly so I think maybe the
best way to approach this for Kelly is
why not just ask them the same question
you just asked us how can I lovingly
express that how I feel about your
collection yeah here's the thing how can
I tell you in a loving way that this is
stressing me out and how can you help me
because here's the thing you you you're
not pigeon holed you have options you
can get a divorce and never see your
kids again that's an option yeah
probably not a good option not the best
option but here's the thing no matter
what circumstance were in there there
are times where that is a good eye for
me getting a divorce in my own life was
one of the best things that ever
happened to me it was also one of the
best things ever happened to my spouse
now obvious I'm not telling Kelly to do
that but there are times where that is a
appropriate response with respect to
just clutter it has to do with how can I
get you to better under
Stanwell my position is mm-hmm and I
think one of the best ways to do that is
to ask the question here's another pithy
answer for Shawn to put in the notes
here better questions lead to better
solutions and right now Kelly I think
maybe you're asking some questions of
them hopefully you're not just telling
them it doesn't sound like you are it's
what happens with a lot of us or to say
hey Ryan I think you need to get rid of
your whatever your Hummel collection and
and the truth is that Ryan is the thing
if I go to Ryan's house now it may be
cluttered for me he doesn't I don't
think your house would be cluttered for
99.9% of of the world but when you and I
live together Ryan you're you respected
what my my needs were because I I think
it did a pretty good job communicating
what those needs are and asking the
right question and it wasn't me
begrudging you and saying you shouldn't
have this or you you you can't do this
it was trying to explain where I was
coming from and I think one of the best
ways to do that is start asking some
better questions absolutely yeah might
be the answer is this asking loved ones
for support especially when you've
supported those loved ones is the best
help anyone could ask for
it's it's well first off Josh you and I
say this all the time about the best way
to to have someone support you is to
support that person yeah um you and I
cannot reiterate that point enough when
you go out of your way the reason why I
went out of my way to support you when
we were roommates is because you go out
of your way to support me and we've
always done that for each other I don't
know who you know started supporting who
first but we've always done that for
each other but all that expectation
right so yes with that right exactly I
can't say well you know what I'm going
to help Ryan do the dishes today so
hopefully he'll help me repair my bike
tonight or something like the
contribution doesn't work like that
right and I have had other roommates
where I do not I will not go out of my
way to support them because they do not
they did not go out of their way to
support our living environment or maybe
you did go out of your way for a while
but then they took advantage of it sure
and then you're like well screw
if people were taking advantage of my
support then why am i going to continue
to be support right there is one
particular situation where yeah like
that's exactly how it unfolded and I got
out of that situation no longer lived
with that person right and I was with
him for about a year we were roommates
for a year and a half two years and it
was yeah it was it was not the best
situation so I changed it sure
um what when I had that option so yeah
obviously um
Kelly's got a loving family and she
obviously supports them so I feel like
they're gonna support her so yeah I am
echoing what you're saying josh is she
just needs to lovingly ask them for
their support it doesn't mean that they
have to get rid of their collection but
is there a way for them to still have
their collection but also maybe have the
house feel a little less cluttered so
Kelly you're asking the right questions
you're asking us the right questions you
just now have to ask your family that
same question yeah and maybe another
question to ask them then Ryan is what
problem does decluttering solve for them
because right now they don't see a
problem at all right and if she's
offering a solution to a problem that
doesn't exist for them and why would you
want that right if I keep telling you
Ryan I've got the best nail polish that
you're gonna it's gonna make your hands
look great you're like I don't have that
problem and so I don't really need that
right and I think with your families
right now they don't see what the
solution is for and so maybe you can
answer this sort of quietly to yourself
what problem does decluttering solve for
you and then what problem would
decluttering or letting go of a
collection solve for the other people in
your family and once you understand that
you'll start to understand what the
benefits of that letting go are and then
you can better communicate that and you
can better open up the lines of
communication no the last thing I'll say
here is you know I don't know how old
you are Kelly let's assume you're 30
years old here and and and you it took
you 30 years to get to this point of
letting go of a collection and and to
expect someone else to instantly adhere
to that same revelation you had 30 years
in or 35 years or 40 years or however
long it's been you know what it's it's
going to be really difficult for you to
get someone to change it
took you 30 years to build a house
trying to get someone else to build it
overnight is virtually impossible so
keep in mind they're not in the same
place that you are but you can you can
show them the recipe that you you you
put together to get there and perhaps
they can get there in a more direct
fashion because you took a circuitous
route to get there maybe there's a more
direct path but also don't expect it to
to happen overnight all right our next
question is from Haley Haley asks what
fuels people's desire let me try that
again Millie what fuels people's desire
to collect in the first place well my my
short answer is I think I have two short
answers here my first one is we often
collect things to mask our hoarding and
we just talked about that what the
collecting is dangerous I say sometimes
like it just sounds nice because to say
I have a collection stay instead of
saying I have a hoard right but
sometimes we have a whole I had a hoard
of Al Pacino memorabilia which sounds
just terrible to say right I get a
little embarrassed even even saying that
I had emotions I would feel embarrassed
right now
and and I think hoarder instead of
saying like Oh mo hoarder Lake look at
my newspaper collection oh this is this
is perfect I was gonna wait till next
week when we talk about decorations to
talk about this is as soon as you said
that so I have a bookshelf right with 40
50 60 books but however many books are
on them I don't I don't count my things
right it fits all my books and then I
actually want to put a new book on there
I have to take one off and like get rid
of it so like there's because I'm not
gonna have a second third books at least
I'm not going with you right now if I
decide to in the future I'm gonna do so
intentionally but but here's the thing I
was thinking like getting this beautiful
magazine rack that I've been looking at
getting because I have I eat week I read
The New Yorker and Bex gets like dwell
magazine and occasionally will get the
catalog from Design Within Reach and
and I like looking at these magazines
but then like having a magazine rack
means well Imli can hoard these
magazines right but how is that
different from my book collection well I
can I can honestly say how it's
differently because there's different
uses and the books in my book collection
ones I like my favorite books I'll in
doubt with magazines I don't have the
same sort of affinity for magazines and
so for me it would be a way to say look
at my magazine collection no it's just a
hoard it's a it's a small horde of
magazines and when I say it like that
I'm like screw that I'm not spending the
$20.00 or whatever our $50.00 on this
magazine rack that's why am I gonna
waste that money if just to to
supplement my hoard and so I think it's
run the language we use yeah the other
the other fit the answer that the
minimal maximum that I would have here
would be insecurity leads to collecting
hmm and and and it's nothing I was
talking about earlier Ryan it's like
well man I will be a more complete
person like I mean complete now but if I
just have this collection if I get this
thing just right then I will be just
right yeah that's right along the lines
of my pity answer my pity answer is
having the complete collection will not
by default make one complete and I think
ultimately what you're talking about is
why a lot of people do collect some
people will truly have collections of
things that they love and it fuels their
life and it really does augment their
life in a positive way but I totally
agree there is a percentage of people
obviously not every single person I
don't even want to put a percentage on
it but certainly there is a percentage
of people who they they will feel like
having a complete collection of
something is going to help them somehow
be complete as a human being someone
actually told me because I was talking
about how I bite my nails all the time
and pick up my nails and someone was
explaining to me they're like dude that
is a that is a mental thing where
because I was explaining to them how
I've got like right now I've got this
little edge on my thumb and I'm like off
I could just get that one little edge
that and make that smooth it'll be so
perfect and there were like that is a
symptom of Lake your overarching
thoughts of yourself yeah that you don't
feel like you are a hundred percent
complete so you pick your nails and if
you could just get that one edge a
little bit more smooth you could be that
much closer to being complete and it
just like blew my mind when we're
explaining this to me
so maybe what maybe maybe the antidote
to that is embrace the incompleteness
right because it is going to be
incomplete
it's everything's impermanent yeah and I
mean how do we even define complete
anyway because eventually you're gonna
die that's the only way to truly be
complete is you've completed your life
and now you're dead no matter what your
thoughts are about afterlife or lack
thereof like that's the the end of a
complete life it's a complete lifecycle
but in the meantime you're going to be
incomplete and and no matter how many
things you collect no I'm gonna no
matter how many hoards that you have no
matter how many nails I bite yeah you're
not gonna be completely never gonna be a
hundred percent complete and that's okay
yes so man there's some sort of metaphor
really a nail biting and collecting you
know actually hang on to the nails or
anything do you of course not that's
crazy I just might be very clear for
anyone listening out there it there
because I'm sure there's someone who you
know maybe is listening to this maybe
their spouse is listening to this
episode and like they're just they just
happen to be catching some of it in the
background while their spouse is
listening to it yes and they might be
thinking like these guys are crazy I
have a collection I love it it adds a
ton of value to my life if you're that
person great like I'm not gonna be that
person personally and that's great too
yeah yeah and and the question then is
what is appropriate for my life yeah and
and it's not going back to those rules
it's not my rule isn't I'm not going to
have a collection mm-hmm
my rule is the things that I bring into
my life serve a purpose or bring me joy
and if a collection somehow falls under
that whether it's my bookshelf or if I
wanted to go get a Precious Moments
collection sometime in the future
because I thought it was so beautiful
right and so be it it just has to fit
the rules of my own life and the good
news is you get to make those rules as
well hopefully some of our rules will
yeah but but you get to decide all right
it's time for our added value portion of
the show this is where we each talk
about something that has added value to
our lives recently it doesn't mean we're
recommending it for you but it's
something that has added value to our
lives recently and so this really has
nothing to do with collecting but I have
a new album you can add to your music
collection I have been playing this
thing out we were playing in the car on
the way to the airport the other day
Ryan mm-hmm and Jack Harlow yeah that's
great as an album called it's a
technical mixtape who knows what the
hell that means anymore
it's called gazebo it's a 10-track album
and it is so good and then I sold a
video let's put a link to the video man
he doesn't look anything like I imagined
he would have looked like mmm he's a 19
year old kid from Louisville and it's
just it's so far it's my album of the
year album of 2018 Jack Harlow gazebo in
fact if it's okay with shot and we play
a snippet of one of my favorite songs on
that he's got a bunch like the whole
thing is great the the second song on
the album is called routine let's play
snippet of that real quick actually you
know what let's listen to the the intro
from gazebo what's the song called
Eastern Parkway and it kind of lets you
feel the vibe it sets up the album
really well and it's a good song to play
at night if you just if you're just
riding in the car Eastern Parkway Jack
Harlow did that belly did that come out
this year was belly this year that's
last year no that was last year yeah
yeah I think I recommended I'm on a path
Spock yeah well it's funny cos like I'm
just now getting into that album yeah
even though you recommended it and it's
late yeah that's a really good one one
two my point is is like the that heart
that Jack Harlow album is probably like
it's the best like newest hip hop album
I've heard yeah and belly was probably
that like the before Jack Carla was my
favorite new hip hop album yeah I really
think both of those albums you've got
anything that's added value to your life
I do man I was um so I went went to Las
Vegas so I went to go visit our old
friend
the corporate world you might mike yeah
he's my favorite person I've ever fired
I love that story yeah yeah he's doing
great man him and his partner went out
and visited them so I went to this this
restaurant in Las Vegas called sake Rock
okay let me make sure I got this right
so there's this dude out there
yeah it's sake rock and I'll make sure
there's a link to it in the show notes
but there's this guy out there where he
was like hey man you're the minimalist
guy man if if you like my food like do
you mind giving it a mention I'm like no
like I totally give recommendations all
the time in on my podcasts or on Twitter
or whatever like as long as it's genuine
recommendation we don't do any
advertisements or anything and yeah long
story short the food was it's the best
sushi I've ever had in Las Vegas for
sure so if you're in the Vegas area like
I would totally recommend it but the
food was awesome and I'm like alright
Nick like this was really good food I
will totally right make sure to
recommend this man
and so yes Sakhi rockin Vegas soon
that's why I love love being able to do
this without without advertisements
because it's like yeah we could make
money from people paying us to talk
about their thing but for me being able
to recommend you know the Jack Harlow
well because there was something about
just listen album where I felt 19 again
and in a way that was like like
optimistic and and enjoy like just did
the the the the his albums called gazebo
and I heard him and in an interview I
had you call him cuz he's evil he goes I
just appreciate sitting in a gazebo he's
I just think they're really underrated
he's like I appreciate things that
people generally don't appreciate like
park benches like if I see a park bench
I'm gonna go sit on the park bench I'm
like yes that's being 19 like I remember
like just go hang out in a parking lot
somewhere with friends at age 19 and and
and the here's the cool thing is like
you can do that now right like Bex and I
will just go like we went to LACMA this
weekend and just like like walk the
aisles and and and took some edibles and
and like everything was instantly
profound right
and and like you can as a 19 year old
you don't have to be 19 to experience
that feeling of optimism and youth you
can experience it through the music and
so that's why that album really really
stood out to me it's about the
experiences that we have and not these
collections to get back to the
collecting started yeah the collection
is and so what you're talking about with
the sushi restaurant is you had a great
experience if I totally forgot to
mention speaking of music they had they
do a performance while you're eating -
what do you mean it's like the when I
was there it was kind of like a like a
drag show but it was freaking awesome
like the music was great performance was
great okay and it's why you eat and it's
not intrusive at all like a lot of the
dinner theater's is kind of it's weird
like eating and watching theater but
like they do it in a really awesome way
yeah but anyway no I mean I'm sorry to
interrupt what the point that you were
making but you're not interrupt anything
we're having a conversation yeah but I I
do totally agree man well I think what's
cool too about our recommendations is
like people know that they're like very
genuine recommendations yeah and again
may not be for you like even your
recommendation right now I was gonna say
to me to rub it in your face
this is you right now because the whole
mercury poisoning thing and so I can't
do fish seafood in general but I can
still appreciate your experience and
your appreciation of of the experience
and just because I like an album doesn't
mean you will either but Jack Harlow if
you're out there and you and you you
hopefully you can appreciate the fact
that I appreciate your music even though
we're in completely different worlds you
were young enough to be my son
I basically what he's saying jack is can
he be your dad yeah can I be your
adoptive stepdad I know you already have
parents but if you if you need another
father figure I'm happy to to to lend in
here or or any other I was gonna make a
great step system that's right you could
follow her on Twitter at ello sandwich
alright y'all it's time for right here
right now so we talked about what's
going on in the lives of
minimalists around we've got some stuff
going on we already mentioned we're
filming a new documentary if you want to
be a part of that you can be part of the
the live studio audience the 3 p.m. show
sold out in a few hours so we added a
second talk at 7 p.m. it's February 10th
you can find all the details to that
over at the minimalists comm slash tour
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well it's February 10th man I
can't wait to to share this documentary
with the world I think I think it's
going to be outstanding and especially
cuz we got Matt back on board he
directed the the documentary and we're
going for a repeat of something
meaningful I feel like we really created
something meaningful it's time to go
back to that and create something else
meaningful for for the folks out there
and we are ending our lessons now tour
we're doing the International dates in
Australia we have seven dates we're
gonna be in Perth Adelaide Brisbane
Sydney Melbourne and Oakland a few of
those are already sold out and a few
others were really close to selling out
if you want tickets to any of our all
Australia dates it's throughout the
month of March you can follow the dates
all the theaters I'll take it
information over at the minimalists comm
slash tour also if you want the show
notes too I always mention the show
notes but we put everything we talked
about today whether it's links or
articles or recommendations it all of
these are in our show notes we email
those right to you they're on our
website so you go over to the
minimalists com enter your email address
we'll never send you spam because spam
is disgusting but we will email you the
show notes anytime a new episode is out
there also new on our website by the
time this comes out it's a new essay
about how the minimalists are using
social media in 2018 maybe next week
Ryan you know I can talk a little bit
about some of the lessons we learned
this this week this month being off of
social media and what we learned what we
thought we would learn but didn't learn
and how we're gonna use social media
more deliberately going forward there's
an essay on the website right now also
if you if you're on an email list you
already have access to that it goes out
to to your email oh and this week on
overtime so each week Ryan and I record
a private podcast is called the
minimalists private podcast for
exclusively for our patreon supporters
because advertisements
we refuse to pepper this podcast with
advertisements instead we are a hundred
percent listener-supported so we're
answering the following question this
week on the overtime episode on the
minimalist private podcast Anthony asks
I have two collections and I'm having an
impossible time letting go
impossible time I've called I've
collected comic books for 15 years and
Boy Scout patches for 30 years I'm 35
years old now and I've started to pare
down the Boy Scout patches but I keep
finding myself buying more comics so how
do we deal with continuing to buy things
that were collecting and deal with that
impulsive collected we're gonna answer
that on overtime now I know what you're
thinking if you're listening as at home
you guys are really gonna make me like
log on to a website and to listen to
that extended overtime podcast no here's
the good thing about the minimalist
private podcast it is a separate podcast
feed but it shows up right there in your
podcast app next to this podcast so if
you listen to this podcast on say a
Tuesday on Wednesdays when the overtime
episode comes out it shows up right in
your podcast feed you just need the
private podcast link that we send out to
you also this Friday we are going to
publish on patreon also in that private
podcast feed our philadelphia event we
did an event in Philadelphia last year
and we recorded it and that's going out
exclusively for our patreon supporters
so a full hour-long event that we that
we did we answered questions live in
front of that sold-out philadelphia
audience also video podcast coming soon
as we mentioned at the opening of this
if you're interested in watching some
snippets of the podcast or full episodes
of the podcast coming soon youtube.com
slash the minimalists if you do want to
support us on patreon if you want to be
a supporter of the minimalists just go
to the minimalists com click on donate
at the top there then you'll have the
option to do patreon or venmo or PayPal
if you're a patreon supporter though you
get access to all of the private
podcasts also our monthly live streaming
that we do where we answer questions we
call it ask the minimalists anything so
a bunch of really cool perks plus you
get advanced tickets to any event that
we're going to do you get access before
the general public that's all I got
right now Ryan you got
thing else for us I've got some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners if you're interested I am
listen I said listen he did say lism but
yeah but what the heck let's listen yeah
let's listen to these questions
what would Froy say Troy to say about
that what would fry a my name is
Courtney and I'm from Abilene Texas I
was calling with a comment for the young
girl from the horizons podcast I just
wanted to say that I personally was able
to pay for my entire college through
scholarships and so I wanted to present
that to her as an extra way to pay for
college she can google them she can use
different scholarship resources and so I
think that's an extra way that he could
earn money hi Josh and Ryan this is
heather from san diego and i have a tip
for Beth from your most recent episode
called resonate Bev asked for advice
about dealing with beauty products as a
minimalist I've been able to pare down
my product collection quite a lot since
I started my minimalism journey about a
year ago one thing that has helped me so
much is joining the project pan
community this is a community on the
internet you could just search for
project pan on YouTube and Instagram
that makes games and challenges out of
using up your makeup everyone is very
supportive people get really excited
when they hit pan on products that
eventually use them up doing project
pans has taught me how long it takes to
use the products and help me to buy a
lot less being aware of expiration dates
of makeup also helps to pare down your
collection knowing that a foundation
only has a year-long shelf life and
takes about 6 months or more to use Bob
will prevent you from buying or owning
more than 2 at a time
I know Ryan mentioned the 20/20 rule
which doesn't always work especially if
you don't own only drugstore makeup
products most makeup does cost more than
$20 however the 9090 rule works pretty
well for some makeup products when
considering their expiration date
remember that open tubes of mascara
should be thrown out after three months
every time you use it more bacteria gets
into the
product which is pretty dangerous
considering how close the wand gets to
your eye
also think about how you like to use
makeup you like to keep it simple or do
you like to have choices if you like to
have choices there are so many versatile
products on the market that many people
already have in their collections
consider rotating through your eyeshadow
palettes doing a one month one palette
challenge to give your older palette
some love you can do this with blood
products to challenge yourself to wear a
different shade every day for a week
finally Beth you mentioned wanting to
purchase more ethically I recommend
looking into the cruelty free movement
cruelty free kitty and logical harmony
are great resources online best of luck
on your journey hi my name is Jeannette
and I'm from Los Angeles and this
message is for the person that was on
because V becoming episode asking about
what to do with religious items that she
wants to get rid of but she doesn't want
to just throw in the trash they there
are a lot of hospitals Catholic
hospitals that have gift shops and the
babe would probably be happy to have a
donation of Cross like hers that she
could donate and somebody else would be
happy to have alright so that's it for
this episode if you have a question for
the minimalists especially we have a
comment please we need more comments we
need your help on those four oh six two
one nine seven eight three nine you can
also email a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists comm right from your
phone and if you leave here with just
one message we hope it's this love
people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a gray oh I
bet that you'll be fine
without your team
[Music]
you